this is some of the biggest space
exploration news in a long time NASA
Administrator Jim bridenstine has
announced that NASA plans to go back to
the moon twice eventually having four
astronauts living on the moon for two
weeks extraordinarily exciting
development very rarely ena sometimes
there was an exoplanet found with
roughly the weather that would
hypothetically allow certain forms of
life to exist you know 50 light years
away or whatever okay this is really
exciting in the immediate lots of new
technology will be involved including
something called the lunar gateway which
will be an orbiting lunar outpost that
can be sort of a reusable lunar lander
system for astronauts this is a two
mission plan the next immediate mission
is supposed to be by 2024 it will be two
astronauts going up to the moon for
about a week doing up to four spacewalks
doing a bunch of experiments a rover
will be sent to the moon ahead of time
part two will be another mission where
four astronauts will go to the moon for
a 14-day mission this will be sometime
in the next ten years not exactly moving
at the speed of light see what I did
there for lack of a better term but
still a specific plan and proposal so
the next roadblock happens to be getting
the money to get all of this going
Congress has not yet approved the
funding for this the first part again is
set to happen by 2024 so we've got to
get NASA that money now let's go through
the sort of depressing caveats here
Trump
sometimes seems to be into space travel
stuff other times no it's clear he
doesn't understand most of it but Donald
Trump has been pretty hostile to NASA
because of the climate research that
they do so he may lobby against giving
NASA the money to do this but especially
if a Democrat wins the White House in
2020 we've got a better shot at getting
NASA the money to at least start part
one of this - mission series number two
there have actually been lots of return
to moon projects over the last couple of
decades none of which have happened and
that's also a depressing reality
honestly this is doable and exciting
enough that I bet if now
tried to crowd fund it or crowd fun part
of it in conjunction with a few key
billionaires making some big donations I
wouldn't be shocked if they could put
together a big part of the money that
would be required for this but this also
comes down to national priorities space
exploration has been great historically
for research and development for the
military which is less my priority but
it's appealing to some but we're also at
a point technologically right now where
we have so much new technology that will
allow us to do more in space than we've
ever done which in turn can help us
develop new technology to be used here
on earth potentially to deal with
climate change with energy with
conservation transportation aviation I
mean it's an almost limitless list and
that's why it's particularly depressing
to see not just elected officials
sometimes oppose this type of research
they like to say oh it's wasteful
spending it's depressing that even just
average people get bamboozled into
thinking this is not how we should be
spending money no this is how we should
be spending money endless wars hundreds
of military bases around the world
replacing weapons we've never used and
are likely never to need because that's
the way that we've decided we're gonna
do some of these military industrial
complex contracts with big defense
contractors that's wasteful spending
pushing the limits of humanity into
space for the potential betterment of
science and technology that actually
seems like a good use of money both
economically and culturally for
geopolitical relations and yet it's just
so damn depressing you have a large
contingent of our elected officials and
even just of people on our on in our
country that oppose it and III wish it
would change I don't know what needs to
happen for it to change but at least
this hopefully is the start hopefully
it's the catalyst of getting back to the
moon
a very common refrain by the way is
every time the idea of going to Mars is
mentioned whether it's the Mars one
project or NASA doing it or some other
company you have a lot of people who say
listen we got to get back to the moon we
haven't been to the moon for decades
we've got to do that first here's a
proposal to do it and I hope that this
is something that happens I look forward
to it
we will see ultimately what happens and
whether the funding is put together